long before it hit theaters Avengers
infinity war had Marvel fans guessing
who would live who would die and what
would happen if and when Thanos got his
hands on the Infinity stones
now that the movies out though the
speculation hasn't stopped and some fans
have a new theory that might change
everything in the unlikely event that
it's actually true if you haven't seen
infinity war yet
be careful we're about to get into some
deep spoiler territory one of the most
shocking moments of the film comes right
at the start when Thanos kills Loki
Thor's occasionally supervillainess
brother it certainly seems like a
definitive end to Tom Hiddleston's fan
favorite character but since we've seen
Loki died before and returned through
trickery and illusions a few moviegoers
are wondering if there might be
something more than meets the eye going
on here a new theory brought up by
journalist John L Dickey mapped out in
detail by screen rams thomas bacon
suggests that Loki didn't actually die
instead he's alive and well and
masquerading as Bruce Banner Dickey
notes that Loki's dagger sneak attack on
Thanos was feeble he knew it wouldn't
work suggesting that the whole thing was
a ruse to allow Loki to sneak back onto
earth further evidence comes from the
view that aside from not being able to
turn into the Hulk there was something a
little bit off about banner in the rest
of the movie I don't know maybe the fact
that I was trapped for two years inside
of a monster made me a little worried
according to the theory he's
particularly odd in his passionless
interactions with Black Widow it's been
a few years since their romance was
teased in Avengers age of Ultron
but since banner doesn't remember the
years he spent as the Hulk those
memories should be pretty fresh in his
mind the theory also posits that banners
inner struggle with Hulk may actually be
down to Loki disguising himself as the
super-smart scientist but being
unwilling to impersonate the
not-so-jolly giant thanks to their
somewhat contentious history with each
other
dickie also suggests that this might be
the reason why banner landed directly in
dr. Strange's sanctum sanctorum when he
returned to earth
loki has encountered the master of the
mystic arts before so it's possible that
he may have directed his path from outer
space towards dr. strange knowing he'd
be a quality choice to spearhead the
fight against Thanos if all of this is
true it could mean that the Hulk wasn't
even on the Asgardian refugee ship at
the start of infinity war escaping with
Valkyrie the breakout character of Thor
Ragnarok who is expected to return in
the future MCU film the only problem is
that well it's probably not true at all
if you take Occam's razor - the Loki as
banner theory you'll find there's a much
simpler explanation for all of its
points for starters by the time tano's
shows up on the S guardianship he's
already dealt with Loki before and knows
how he operates he be prepared for and
expecting deceptive tactics like
illusions in shape-shifting second and
probably most importantly banners
struggles with the Hulk make a lot more
sense as banner actually struggling with
the Hulk
rather than Loki working a long con on
the Avengers the Hulk's encounter with
dados marks the first time that the
green Goliath has been so easily
defeated in a fight which would shatter
his confidence and explain why he's so
unwilling to make a return also there
are several scenes in infinity war where
banner attempts to turn into the Hulk
when no one is around to see it that
would only make sense for Loki if he
suddenly had Deadpool levels of
fourth-wall breaking self-awareness
banners arrival at the sanctum sanctorum
is pretty easy to explain away with
magic but probably happened because that
scene is lifted from the original comics
the only difference is that there it's
the Silver Surfer who ruins strangest
staircases
but since he doesn't currently exist in
the MCU banner makes a fitting
substitute as for banners encounter with
Black Widow there actually is some
tension there but it's certainly not the
focus that however is easily explained
by the fact that the romance teased an
age of Ultron wasn't exactly the best
part of that movie some viewers felt
like it came out of
where and didn't really serve either
character well so it makes sense that
the next film might down plan or maybe
Bruce Banner just doesn't prefer blondes
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
plus check out all this cool stuff we
know you love to
[Music]